hey guys so right now I'm on the set of
brand page and I'm so excited because
we're here in Atlanta Georgia and we're
getting a sneak peek behind the scenes
on the set a huge thank you to Warner
Brothers for sponsoring this video and
set tour and also stay tuned because in
a little bit we'll be chatting with
Dwayne Johnson right now let's walk
around the set and see some things this
set is so great so basically this is the
Federal Plaza in Chicago and it is
completely just destroyed there is
destruction everywhere there's just crap
just all going to the place that has
been destroyed
pretty cool
[Music]
so the whole premise is we're going to
chat about mutations because so much
stuff in the film has to do with animal
mutations so we've got some Photoshop
mutations here then we're going to think
we can figure out what they were
previous to their mutations I also have
a special surprise back in 2008 the
first time I've ever done a red carpet
event this photo right here
photoshopping my face onto Duane's face
and I made him sign one of these and
then I gave him one that I signed for
him super disturbing we were on set all
day today we saw so many crazy things
there was like a massive airplane but
the crazy part about is it was kind of
like three different sections so we have
a big cargo plane and a c-17 that is
transporting without giving the movie
way that is transporting one of our big
genetically mutated animals whose
massive having George on that plane it's
a big mistake I think we'll be alright
and then we also have which I believe
you thought today was part of a on a lot
of Chicago is is what do we call that Oh
completely demolish its destroyed
genetically altered animals and see if
we can figure out what they are perfect
thank you this is my jam let me just
give context to everyone watching so hi
this is part of my makeup right she just
didn't like kick me and bring me in this
concern when I gave you a hug I was like
is this movie makeup or is this ocean
scratch the blood what do we think this
is that is dog mixed with a pig hey bug
boy okay I do his name is Maddie Maddie
actually I think I might have something
in here oh great this is my face I'm
Maddie
yes it's very very cute is there a
combination of a name like that we have
oh no um let's see here's a little
number hurt oh so nothing that you what
don't worry love you too is this
potentially your dog it is potentially
my my dog's face on it as if they'd like
they they amalgam eyes that's me it's
the bald eagle cuz it's all that's wrong
okay good yeah we've so many of you oh
my tattoo is there look at that I wish I
could say I Photoshop I was gonna say
kid I did it I could but I did it so we
have one last one okay and this is
extremely embarrassing I hope you don't
remember this you were one of the first
people I ever interviewed on a red
carpet and I don't even want to show
this to be really embarrassing this was
in 2008 in Las Vegas but there's a catch
all right please don't remember ever
signing this oh my god so there was like
this kiosk and you could put your face
on somebody else's body
and it just so happened that I was going
to interview I saw this kiosk so I I
signed one I gave it to you and then I
had you sign this and it is terrifying
and Wow so this I mean this if you've
ever wondered what Justine would look
like with a really thick neck
I believe it's like a healthy this is
the second time well so everybody knows
when I first walked in the room I gave
Jesse in a big hug because I felt like I
was like dude I feel like I'm knocking
for such a long time if you follow each
other on Twitter we want to comment on
things and now I realize we met many
years ago in base this I never want to
forget again yes this is this is me
after the operation yes well thank you
so much but you see the film and we will
see you guys the beer
[Music]